nein wer gaskraftwerke die seh mich
nicht
willkommen zu einer weiteren folge
minecraft mit dabei der macht was gilt
dass so etwas geht okay wir müsst ihr
euch gleich alles erklären aber jetzt
erstmal in 54 32 19
ich war in italien beziehungsweise im
bus von italien zurück bis vor fünf
minuten war ich im bus und ich bin
gerade zur tür reinkommt hier herunter
ja ich komme hinterher warte aber noch
als zweiter nach rechts
halb so schlimm hat bestand
vw habe ich dies nicht weiter sinken wir
das nicht okay aber wir bleiben in der
mitte stehen ja ja ja weiter spiele
kommt jemand über uns wahrscheinlich
muss man manchmal zu
ok alter ist das gras mit so vielen
leuten heute server zu sein
ok wurden bewegen wird und 19
oder wollen lasst uns lasst uns hier
unter der erde schauen wer sich oben
bewegt wenn so eine weich oder
irgendjemand sonst natürlich jemand wir
wollen auf jeden fall halten aber jetzt
halt nicht gegen krasse leute richtig ja
also was machen wir ja ich die sache
kommen wir bei uns einfach in die
richtung aber schön sneakers
ok also max wies heute um man bislang 36
37 das alles so was schon fertig 13
stunden fahrt und gestern abend
aufnehmen letzter abend wir haben
dementsprechend gefeiert ich habe zwei
stunden schlafen heute nacht keine
sekunde im bus weil es unbequem das [ __ ]
war und ich wäre eine halbe stunde zu
spät zum termin gekommen
wenn man zwei minuten schon zu spät
kommt normalerweise dann fliegt man raus
war komplett es gibt keinen zwang das
war auf jeden fall haben wir es so
geregelt
dank den anderen hätten teilnehmer so
groß an euch +100 dass ihr weiter runter
gehen werden dann alle geschlagen
die sind auf jeden fall so tolerant und
haben gesagt dass wir auch gerne halbe
schon später aufnehmen können wie haben
jetzt auch max gewartet max pünktlich
23.30 und jetzt können wir jetzt alles
hier aufnehmen sonst welche komplett
alleine gewesen hätten wir 20 uhr gesagt
alter recht korrekt von denen leute
gestorben eigentlich schon heute jetzt
gerade wieder krass oder
ja ich hätte gedacht dass losgeht login
ok dann wir reinkommen
wir haben noch keine krassen sachen ich
will mir jedenfalls dass du auch eine
die hose hast also gehen wir uns oder er
würde auch sagen leute ich muss sagen
wir nehmen jetzt vier folgen am stück
auf richtung volksstück und mit einem
mal drei folgen morgen auch 5
wir brauchen geld kommt dem vorhaben
konnte haye nur drei folgen darf man
noch aufnehmen ihr bekommt jetzt
streiken ein alter das machen wir wegen
der gamescom ja genau und leute ich bin
nicht so krass von 14 gewann aber diese
kamera überbelichtet mich irgendwie ein
bisschen wie soll auch keiner tod erst
mal ein bisschen pushen hier wurden
gehen jetzt auf unsere höhe oder wie im
richtigen pc zu viele leute ist es was
habe ich durchgemacht dieses jahr es
wirklich ich musste mir gut überlegen
steige ich aus bei einem halt und setzte
mich an die raststätte an der autobahn
da war oder was weiß ich nehme mir ein
taxi in die nächste stadt und geht einen
irgendwie so ein hotel oder sowas in dem
dort auf leute mein herz ich bin sowas
von am arsch das war hierfür für
zuckerrohr eine kleine baseball row dann
pflanzen wir das hier an
ich bin sehr lustig was den job
gold-favorit hat holt gold
wenn jetzt hier ankommt das ist übrigens
die hardcore taktik was wir machen
freunde ja das ist doch man kann
wir hatten jetzt geguckt und wenn einer
bei hätten gekämpft wenn nicht wir
müssen halt weil alle teams haben
piloten hat für die diamond alter
bisschen aufholen aber alles alleine
alleine und wir haben soll doppelt so
schwer es enten werden genauso schwer
wie er muss für eine person die as roma
ich bin echt irgendwie leicht
überfordert werde aber sie nach leute
das war wirklich es ihm wirklich kraft
aber ich bin auch was ich frage mich
wirklich was von wenig macht jetzt hier
in fünf folgen nach was denkt und vor
allem allerdings an sun ausgang von der
hölle stellen weil locker in der hölle
oder so oder werden da reingehen muss
wenn man raus will dann kommt man zu der
partei hast du wasser mit dem wir
eigentlich auch kein wasser alberne ich
habe ein zwei vielleicht sollte ich ein
wassereimer es wäre nicht schlecht alter
wie viel hast du ich hab 89
okay wir brauchen ab 16
ich warte hier ich habe 16 flint shop
wasser noch eine feder ein alter [ __ ]
sich die gelaufen sind
ich hoffe ja ganz media ich habe 16
klingt ja kann man kein player liegen
kommt er sprach ich mal ganz so da
wollen wir uns hier langsam wieder hoch
graben das hält mir jetzt nicht kurz
noch vielleicht ein bisschen wenigstens
diese zwei folgen wenn ihm heute vier
folgen auf das zweite von sydney ja aber
ich würde sagen dass wir so einen
unterirdischen tunnel am einer führt
direkt beim bauern hoch und der andere
ist schön abseits vom sport ab so dass
man entkommen kann
genau das bekommen kann okay das
eigentlich ganz golden oder ja ich wäre
total okay dann kannst du das man nicht
machen das spezielle baut hier schon mal
so langsam wieder vor
hier können wir das ein bisschen klein
strippen gezogen was dir helfen kann
das wird mein oder sowas in kraft ist
ich mache ein gold apfel kann ich schon
mal einen apfel ich habe leider keinen
abbruch
ja ich hab jetzt nur einen gold ab aber
immer in einer wollen wir vielleicht
einen tank von uns machen wir alles ein
steckt und die guten sachen krieg beim 1
also ich habe jetzt schon die besten von
uns ich habe 90 punkte durch lara und
dann könnte ich dir nochmal schaffen es
vier schwert geben dies erst durch
schiffe drei okay und schärfer 1 ja okay
wenn es du halt alles weg denken so ist
so gut im bogen jo ja dann geb ich
jemandem einen bogen dann gehst du eher
auf distanz kampf ich auf links uns ja
nur soll es auch besonders hart auf hart
komme übertrieben guten und dann kommt
noch die hälfte von deinen arrows geben
auf druck von den trainern sich zu
schämen
aber leute ich bin wirklich froh wieder
zuhause sein nach diesem okay was ich
tatsächlich machen werde kann ich nicht
sagen aber nach diesem video
ich habe gefragt ob du hast ja gesagt
eiche ist war stand der erst 20 uhr
und dann habe ich so gern gefragt ja
kann mich 20 30 uhr an der sonne und
dann haben wir es gekonnt wie das
ausgeht abgefragt ja dann bin ich ja
wahrscheinlich alleine da ich mir jemand
dazu holen er nicht mit wasser zu tun
hat der meint so nein natürlich nicht
und dann nicht dass jetzt im hintergrund
ist alles quatsch
nee nee also der gute herr peters in der
ersten
ich glaube nicht dass das ein problem
ist so astrid meinst du da unten von
just in europa hat noch alles was okay
ich bin der schlupf herausgekommen hast
du queenston nicht machen sonst richtig
ja das kommt richtig keine tipps geben
oder so weil nicht dass es kräfte die
sich nicht aggressiv kommt zurück maxime
bitte zurück ok also die köln alles was
nicht bei drei auf dem baum
alter schwede wo mein gott mein herz
hast du greenstone belt gerade ich habe
jetzt drei stücke die die waren zehn
blöcke über mir die waren genau auf
meinem punkt liegen da nicht hingehen da
nicht hingeht dann nicht wenn wir da
nicht hin die an der maschine lassen
dass hier ein zweiter reinbauen das
leichter ich brauche nur die namen sehen
und hab schon herzstillstand was wollen
wir etwas wird zumal mit queenston uns
rogers in angst allerdings braucht die
also hätten hätten wir uns gesehen aber
die alte situation jemand anders gewesen
wissen können dass ich gegen anderes
team gewesen als er wolle jetzt keinen
namen länder war dass ich irgendwelche
die alleine werden oder so hätte hätte
ich auch angegriffen aber nicht so
jemanden weil die sind schon echt krass
nicht mal wenn du jetzt nicht schlecht
die haben es okay aber der eingang zu
dem strip allerdings jetzt natürlich
noch offen weil ich bin ich bin direkt
weg begleiten zu mitgemacht das okay
aber bist du alleine vor jetzt ja ich
sag ich ja alle unsichtbarkeit schreib
mal habe dich gerade gesehen nein neid
fand dass er daran kommt dann jeweils
neben anlass sich unauffällig konnte es
mir gerade so entkommen was denn das ist
so eine offene bühne alter ja ich weiß
um diesen oben direkt an am rand entlang
gelaufen wie solche messen zu wollen
er schreibt ja war mega knapp der kommt
überhaupt nicht darauf dass ich
tatsächlich direkt unter dem schnee
anwälte und ich bin so rot wie
indianercamp piano
ok ok perfekt dass man hier nicht eine
team kiste aufstellen oder ja stimmt
müsste
ben und will also wird game die haben
einfach ihre andere teams die auch die
bergige schreibt haben den geholt und
die haben an ihrem anderen ort die
vergessen das schild von ihrer team
kiste lag zu machen
deshalb ist am set habe ich abgebaut
okay ich bin oder
also ich fühle mich ganz sicher nie
wieder passiert doch abgemacht oder
nichts denn sie mir noch einmal zurück
gelaufen haben wir nicht das vergessen
aber schild hat oder ich wollte die
lecks meines lebens ich weiß nicht was
passiert aber nur zweite sichert dann
ist nicht erlaubt dass steinbach ja
schallte das warten wir gucken gleich
mal der aufnahme noch mal ja wir
brauchen ja unbedingt ein zweites werden
stellt ganz schnell dass viele christen
wir müssen hier nicht mehr beschriften
ich meine kiste
ich habe übrigens lecker ist als
schiller gehört bei mir auch nicht nur
als ein pärchen holz und konvertiert
sind direkt oben da lange gelaufen
glaubt ihr die waren richtig auf der
chase aber die werden kommen da noch mal
zurück gehen aber du musst dann
unbedingt bei mir anschauen das war so
was von knapp also ich hab dir gesehen
nicht nur die namen herzlichen hast du
bestimmt schön drauf gesucht
ich glaube ich auch einfach nur herrlich
verkauft nein ich meine im ach so das
wirst du allemal ja so ihr packe ich
erstmal rheinwassers leder dass ich habe
es gesehen
22 jeder kann ja auch bücher entscheiden
eben das wäre eine gute sache
ok dann brauche ich noch ein bisschen
kohle ab für level und erste folge ist
dann auch gleich rum
wir haben sich das relativ also ich
denke dass es gut aufwachsen
die hälfte von queenston man weiß nie wo
wir ja stimmt wir haben es die hälfte
dieser das habe ich wir haben uns auf
jeden fall eine base gemachten ich
glaube dass es bei fünf folgen gar nicht
mal falsch ja erst mal einen kleinen
rückzugsort hat sei es
man wird angegriffen um namen sondern zu
sagen das stimmt er
wenn uns jemand drücken wollte aber kann
man sich jetzt wohl eigentlich ausloggen
weil wenn man denn wenn gegnern ihr
sehen wobei man darf dem kampf sein oder
ja man darf sich nicht aus lang man muss
gepflegt werden und wenn halt in der
nähe gegner sind dann wirst du bist
nicht hoch was die agenten oder
am eingang unserer nähe oder ich weiß
nicht was für eine alte werte hier
gestrippt meint viel coolness level
ich nehme dich ernst gesehen mehr
produktiv und ernster nehmen diese genau
gelesen können die top concepts grad
erst vor der aufnahme gelesen so dass
mister orientierungssinn sagte mal
wieder zurück ins bett ja sorry leute
besser angeschlagen wer von wer hat sich
denn angeredet
haye hatte wo bist du ich nicke höre ich
darauf hinter dir
rollmann zitiert auf einen meter gar
nicht gelingen
also wir sollten definitiv darum bemüht
sein mir in wasser einfach zu besorgen
ja weil ich nicht löschen kann er war
dabei leider so darunter ok wenn leute
und krasser gästen schnell dass
wenigstens versuchen zurückzukommen
philipp indirekten erklärung war das
hier vor glaube ich dann links war
oder nebel sind hoch gegangen egal
ok folge einziger lebt leute macd server
lässt
wir haben's geschafft bis morgen